[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHERINE MILLER: Hi, Aja.
I hope you're having a good last
day of Google Cloud Next 2018.
AJA HAMMERLY: It's been
fantastic this year.
The event is so huge.
KATHERINE MILLER: Awesome.
I am very excited to learn
more about disruption detector
from you today.
AJA HAMMERLY: So this is a demo
I came up with in December-ish
of this year.
And the goal was to take people
and let them break things,
and then see, in real time,
how our monitoring and logging
and error reporting
systems showed that
so that they had a
better idea of what
it would look like if they used
it for their own applications.
Because we do all these
demos, but the whole goal
of most of the demos is
that everything stays up
all the time.
So you don't get to
see what those bad days
on the internet look like.
And so I wanted to give folks
the opportunity to do that.
So what we've got
going on here is
we've actually got a whole
bunch of different ways
you can break stuff.
The panel behind you has a
bunch of different kinds of HTTP
errors that you can send.
The panel behind
me sends traffic.
And further down, we have
panels that kill load balancers
and kill VMs.
And all of that is acting
against a Kubernetes
application that I'm
running in the background
that we're trying to
keep up, while everyone
at the conference here
tries to take it down.
It's been fantastic.
And then, once you're
done with all of that,
you get to see, up at the
top, how those things look
in Stackdriver in real time.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
And I know you mentioned
a number of products
on Google Cloud Platform,
as well as Kubernetes.
Can you talk a little
bit about the technology
that went into building
disruption detector?
AJA HAMMERLY: So it
wasn't my intent,
but we've actually
managed to use
every single one of Google
Cloud's compute options
in this product or in this demo.
We have Cloud functions backing
both the errors and the load.
We have Kubernetes, obviously,
is the app that we're running.
I am using Compute Engine to run
a cron job that puts everything
back together after
the attendees break it.
And I'm using App
Engine as a test
harness so that I could
build this independently
of the manufacturing
of the demo.
And that's also going
to potentially let
us take this demo
to events where
we don't have this much space.
And we can do it as
a web-based demo.
KATHERINE MILLER:
And what makes this
interesting and useful and
helpful to our developers?
AJA HAMMERLY: So as much as
we don't want it to happen,
stuff always goes wrong.
I was talking
yesterday in my talk
that, even if you write
the best code ever
and your infrastructure
is perfect,
you could always have a
day when a shark bites
through the undersea
fiber cable,
because that's
actually happened.
And so what this
teaches you and teaches
developers is that if they
use Google Cloud's Stackdriver
offering, we have a bunch
of different products
that all play well
together and can give you
an overview of your system,
so you can quickly figure out
what's wrong and then fix it.
And it's really, really
interesting for folks,
because, in the
past, people have
been putting these
technologies together
from a variety of
different vendors.
But if they use Stackdriver
on GCP, they all come.
We have all the
options already here.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Well, thank you very
much for the tour.
And I hope you enjoy the
last day of the conference.
AJA HAMMERLY: You too.
[MUSIC PLAYING]